[Music]
you'll see you babies they're excited to
meet their father I think maybe they got
a good one this is us has Todd at our
heartstrings from the very start 10
episodes later we still fill every high
and low with the Pearson family
now here are 11 of the most
gut-wrenching moments so far tell me to
lose the damn weight this kick-started
Kate's weight-loss journey but it's the
sibling love that melted our hearts big
three big three the big three are as
thick as thieves but that wasn't always
the case in this moment between Randle
and Kevin gave us all the fields go back
there with those people it's the first
time in 36 years you said the woods he's
my brother
that's for their parents our dream
couple I'm gonna be 11 baby
screwed up I'm gonna be a 12 for you
from here out but when we realize Jack
and Rebecca work together anymore in the
present and that Jack actually died it
broke our hearts and clearly broke Kevin
too
why because jack is our favorite TV dad
remember when he saved Thanksgiving
pilgrim
or ask doc to help Rebecca connect with
baby Randal or reminded adult Randall he
wasn't a replacement baby
the moment I saw you I knew you were my
boy cue the tears speaking of Randall
him finding out his mom Rebecca kept his
biological father from him which is
heartbreaking you knew my father you
kept him from me my entire life that
brings us to the most recent
heartbreaking moment
[Music]
jeez
[Music]
tobey's fate is unknown but what we can
count on is this as US will keep us
reaching for the tissues when it returns
January 10 I want to hear what has been
your favorite moment on the show so far
between me at D direct oh so we can weep
together
[Music]
you